foreign
[Music]
Arthur thank you for meeting with me it
is no problem got your message surfed on
a humpback whale came straight back here
from Iceland
cool
uh
listen buddy we're doing a little
housekeeping here at the Justice League
and um I don't know how to say this but
yeah
uh you're fired
wait what'd you say to me well you got
swearers here I know you're not familiar
with the concept of fire because you
live under the sea but uh you could also
say she can't
uh terminated
I think in Britain they say redundant
I bring the might of Atlantis to the
Justice League and you're useful as long
as we happen to be fighting General Zod
uh next to a lake or in Miami or a lazy
river in a water park so you can go off
and save the drowning polar bears but
you won't be here with us Waterboy
Aqua man sorry I'm looking at water boy
or should I call you a puppy Boucher
New Orleans you can do it I can do it I
can do a lot that's exactly what I'm
saying sorry Aquafina oh Aqua man and
you ask anybody on the Justice League
they'll tell you I am an invaluable
member of this Chief okay all right
thisani lay it on me tell me what you
can do Mountain Valley Spring okay I can
communicate with every living creature
living in our vast oceans okay
tuxed fish guys also I'm gonna stop you
right there because I know your powers
talks to fish the rest of the pages
blank for office use only I have sonar
yeah for talking to fish I have super
hearing ah so you can listen to fish I
can breathe underwater cause that's
where the fish you talk to are night
vision so you can find the fish if you
ever want a nighttime chin wag I can do
a lot more than just talk to fish okay I
can transport the entire Justice League
by manipulating the waves of the ocean
oh wow you know what else can transport
people on the ocean
boat are you faster than a boat yeah
yeah I'm faster than a boat like a slow
boat way faster than a slow boat what
about a normal to fastball like a medium
salsa boat
about the same we'll stick to boats you
know what I don't have to listen to this
when I wield the mighty Trident of
Neptune
what's up
that's your Trident yeah try
Trident how many dents you see on that
train yet there's no dents at all man
it's clean
how many pokies bunch I tried it's
supposed to be three there's
three what look one
another one
two
also to
the third one in the middle bro that's a
Spork you idiot you look like an
underwater farmer who grows his own hemp
four out of five dentists agree you're
Trident is inaccurate listen you
insignificant mortal the insults you've
wielded today will never be forgotten I
swear it by the beard of Posas sorry man
I put up with that as long as I could
but as soon as you lean this way you
wafted low tide all over me now it
smells like a bait shop down by the
Bayou in August you smell like a third
date went really well all right stop it
stop that that's what you just did to me
but at least mine smells like cut fresh
Mist listen I don't have to take this
all right I have more power in my scaled
dick than you do my battered friend
you have a scaled dick everybody knew
that that sounds like something I would
say to you to make fun of you but you're
just offering it up you know what let me
speak this in a way you can understand
right
what was that I'm sorry I thought you
could speak sea creature that would eat
my whole ass in Dolphin you know what
I quit
you look like the pool boy in a porno
if you're so helpful to sea creatures
where were you in the documentary The
Cove
hunting
all right
[Music]